all right big news at least for now and
by tomorrow this may be different the
joe biden vaccine so-called mandate as
it is known is going to be
frozen frozen uh thanks to the decision
of a panel of republican appointed
judges now what we call the vaccine
mandate
which is why i said so-called
is the requirement through osha
that companies with more than 100
employees either
have their employees get vaccinated and
prove that they are vaccinated or you
just test them weekly for covid so it's
not much of a mandate but it's a
protocol requirement call it whatever
you want remember that fox news is
protocol or requirement or whatever is
stricter than what joe biden has put in
place via osha at fox you have to prove
your vaccination status or test daily
and wear masks in certain situations all
right well per the washington post a
federal appeals court has suspended has
frozen the biden administration's new
vaccine requirement for private
companies the federal appeals court in
new orleans one of the most conservative
appeals courts in the country
is giving the biden administration until
later today to respond to a lawsuit
filed by republican-led states and
businesses the decision was issued by a
panel of three judges all appointed by
republican presidents this is the u.s
circuit court of
u.s court of appeals for the fifth
circuit
the judges wrote that there was quote
cause to believe
there are grave statutory and
constitutional issues with the mandate
they have stayed the mandate
while it is assessed further
what
started
all of this
was a lawsuit filed late last week just
before the weekend by some republicans
including louisiana attorney general
jeff landry now it's really important
this is a temporary freeze on biden's
quote mandate it is not a ruling on the
merits of the policy they want more time
to look at it
it's important to recall that
vaccination requirements at the state
level
at local levels
by schools by private companies they
have almost
completely held up in court so far
the biden requirement is different in
two ways number one it's broader and
number two it's coming from the federal
government so it is different that
doesn't mean it's not going to
ultimately stand it is also not actually
a mandate since you can test out
doesn't apply to employees who work
remotely or outdoors
doesn't apply to people who physically
work uh where other people don't work or
shop
and as we talked about last week these
requirements
do work to get people vaccinated very
much so you can argue that it should be
against the law
you can argue that it's immoral
but it works and it works really really
well when we look at companies ranging
from united airlines to the new york
police department to all sorts of
companies including ones where people
were claiming i will i'm not going to do
it i'm not going to do it it works very
well now going back to the politics this
ruling was signed by judges one judge
was a reagan appointee just judge edith
jones and then kyle earn uh kyle duncan
and kurt engelhardt both were appointed
by donald trump this was the new
orleans-based fifth circuit
court
considered one of the most conservative
appeals courts in the country it is
likely that other circuit courts even
given the same case would find
differently it is likely that such a
decision would probably not be upheld by
the supreme court if it ever got to that
point although we have a little bit of a
wacky supreme court right now and you
never know
white house chief of staff ron klain was
asked what do you think is ultimately
going to happen he says he's confident
it will be upheld of course he would say
that but let's listen to his reasoning i
want to ask you before i let you go
about the court ruling yesterday on the
vaccine uh on on the vaccine protocols
that osha is putting out
sort of the soft mandate i don't want to
call it a hard mandate because of the
testing option
uh
there's a freeze what does that mean for
the federal government's efforts i mean
do you stop preparing for january 4th in
the moment how does this work
well i think what it means for uh the
time being is that uh the the
effectiveness of that uh vaccine
requirement is is frozen uh i think it
will certainly be well litigated though
well before january 3rd so i'm not sure
really has much practical effect in the
short run uh
look these vaccine requirements have
been litigated up and down the courts
all over the country state requirements
for example one in maine
and every single court before this one
ruled that they were valid the supreme
court has turned back several times
already various efforts to enjoin
other vaccine requirements i'm quite
confident that when this finally gets
fully adjudicated not just a temporary
order right uh the the validity of this
requirement will be upheld it's common
sense chuck if osha can tell people to
wear a hot hard hat on the job to be be
careful on chemicals it can put put in
place these simple measures to keep our
workers safe so of course you would say
that with the trump travel ban with
trump with all sorts of different things
trump did
no matter what courts were doing you
always say i'm confident it will be
upheld until there's actually a decision
otherwise but i do think ron clayne is
correct on this that being said
there's a reasonable question
was this requirement through osha the
best way to deal with anti-vaccine
republicans or has actually served to
energize them further i'm very
interested in how the french have done
it i have a family
uncle cousins in france
and they came to me and they said sir
because that's how my cousins talk to me
they are very respectful of me they said
um you know here in france we have a big
anti-vaccine problem
we have the distrust of government
people who are anti-vax like in the u.s
and we have the distrust of big pharma
people here in france like in the u.s
and you've got a lot of people here who
believe homeopathy will treat or cure or
prevent covid
you've got all of it and if they had
done a mandate in france it would have
been absolute pandemonium france took a
different approach where they said you
don't have to get a vaccine but if you
want to travel you want to go to a movie
theater you want to go to a restaurant
you want to go to the great cafes where
you get the salmon tartare and these
great dishes which i love there
um
if you want to do all of that stuff
you just are going to either need to be
presenting a negative test from i don't
remember if it's 24 how many hours every
single time
or you get vaccinated
and the brilliance of it was it diffused
the narrative of a mandate but it was
like this is something really annoying
and so you had some people from all
walks of the anti-vaccine world
saying
i'm not i'm not for the vaccine
but i just want to do something there's
a specific thing i want to do it's not
about just being able to go to work so
i'm going to go and i'm going to go and
get vaccinated i don't want to have to
test all the time i want every time i
want to go to a restaurant or whatever
the case may be so i'm wondering aloud
is that an approach that could have been
maybe more effective but then you have
the question of
is that something biden could really
even do or does it have to be done at
the state or local level our system is
different than that
which which is the case in in france so
be curious to hear from you about that
one of our sponsors is called privacy
privacy is a totally free service that
i've been using for years privacy lets
me create virtual payment cards with one
click and when i use the virtual card
the money is taken out of my bank
account you can create multiple cards
delete them freeze them set a spending
limit on them let's say i'm signing up
for a free trial and it requires a
credit card privacy will autofill a
virtual card number and then after
signing up i can delete that virtual
card so i know i'm not going to be
charged again something really useful
and very practical or let's say i'm
ordering food over the phone
but i left my wallet somewhere i don't
have my real credit card on me i can use
a virtual card on my privacy mobile app
but really the best part is
you're not out there exposing your real
credit card number so you're not as
susceptible to data breaches and
identity theft privacy is a totally free
service and you'll get five bucks to
spend when you go to privacy dot com
slash pacman the link is right
underneath this video